je vous le disais dans les titres les
aimants politique du jour c'est la venue
d'eric zemmour en meeting ce soir à
chaumont sur tharonne un petit village
solognot de quelques milles âmes un
déplacement sous le signe de la ruralité
ambiance dans les rues de la commune
avec florent clavel
ici des habitants de chaumont sur
tharonne accueilli la venue de leur très
médiatique voisin d'un soir avec un
certain recul bien sûr ils sont surpris
de voir un candidat à la présidentielle
débarqué ici dans leur sologne mais
enfin pour ou contre zemmour pour ou
contre ces propos sulfureux et bien
c'est la démocratie qui s'expriment
chacun devra repenser
nos corps on me drai publics vont faire
ce qu'on veut choisir
vous savez je n'y vois pas
d'inconvénient
pas du tout
il peut être il est peut être bien comme
il est un peu brutal et quoirin tu as
peu surpris qu'ils viennent là
bas parce que c'est un petit village il
faisait des lecteurs sur mon jeu pas ma
tasse de thé mais bon il n'en faut pour
tout le monde mais les gens dangereux
faut toujours faire attention avec les
gens dangereux
voilà eric zemmour est arrivé vers midi
à quelques kilomètres de là montrieux en
sologne pour discuter avec des élus
locaux lesquels mystère on sait que le
candidat d'extrême droite n'a pas encore
tout à fait c'est 500 parrainages le
patron du parti reconquête ensuite
rencontré des familles rejoint par
philippe de villiers et guillaume
pelletier le député du canton chambord
qui est aussi son bras droit est à
l'origine de sa visite ici une visite
avec pour thème central la ruralité je
serai leur président je veux absolument
renverser cette folie depuis 30 ans qui
fait que tout l'argent va dans les
métropoles et les banlieues tout que
tous les laits les gens vont dans les
métropoles s'agglutiner il faut
absolument renverser cette vapeur et
donc je suis là pour pour les écouter
pour ceux qui sont restés et pour savoir
ce qu'ils attendent ce qu'ils veulent et
ce que je ce que je sois ray mais vous
le savez chaque visite zemmour charrie
son lot de polémiques celles ci n'y
échappe pas le maire de chaumont sur
tharonne l'orangé estime avoir été
bernés à l'origine nous at il expliqué
la salle des fêtes avait été réservée
pour une réunion politique de guillaume
pelletier pas pour un meeting
certainement pas pour un mythique d'eric
zemmour at il affirmé sinon il ne
l'aurait pas accepté